family friend says the father was inside
the home near owens and hollywood
with the kids when it started 8 news now
reporter kristen drummond joins us live
in the newsroom with the latest update
kristin
brian and christian family friends
identified the father as quomaine
richardson he does not live in the home
according to a family friend but
richardson
was watching the children while the
mother and her other family members
were at work now this is a photo shared
with eight news now
that's two-month-old london richardson
and two-year-old kwame richardson jr
who actually celebrated his birthday
over the weekend both died when a fire
started tuesday morning in the home and
spread to a bedroom
where they were at the time a neighbor
tells 8 news now the father escaped out
a window but was unable to save his kids
a gofundme page set up by his side of
the family says richardson was taken to
the hospital
and is in critical but stable condition
the account has raised more than
two thousand dollars so far the mother
of the children has a venmo account for
donations to cover funeral expenses
i reached out to both sides of the
family today a family friend tells me
the mom is in shock and trying to
process the sudden loss of her children
the father's family just never got back
to me now the cause of the fire remains
under investigation
but the clark county fire department
tells me it does not seem suspicious
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now